those celebrations in China celebrating
70 years of communist rule it's
President Xi Jinping said no force can
shake the status of his nation but the
lavish parades in the capital Beijing
were overshadowed by anti-china protests
in Hong Kong once again where a man was
shot in the chest today well with me as
the Chinese ambassador to the UK he Xiao
Ming very good to see you ambassador and
can I start with those celebrations in
Beijing of 70 years of the foundation of
the state and we saw their state of the
Arts military hardware intercontinental
ballistic missiles thousands of troops
and the president saying no force can
stop China marching forward should the
world feel a little bit threatened by
all that not at all I think president
made a speech in that speech you said
China will be continued to follow the
path of peaceful development and we
would like to share the opportunities of
China development with the rest of the
world and I think people especially the
media here they focus on one they talk
of a celebration they only focus on the
military parade in fact Manila military
parade is a part of a celebration there
are 15,000 military personnel
participating the military parade but
there are a hundred thousand ordinary
citizens celebrating participating in
the parade there about 70 floats
describing the great achievement Chapman
China has made in the past I mean it is
an amazing achievement from basically a
peasant society to one of the most
advanced economies in the world but I
want to ask you not only the peasant
economy you know the People's Republic
of China was established after a hundred
years of Congolese Wars indeed and
foreign aggression foreign bullying hmm
whilst you ambassador about how that
history informs China's attitude to the
future particularly the foreign bullying
foreign occupations foreign induced Wars
what China wants over the next 70 years
because I've been speaking to you know
him well the dissident I way where you
know
in the UK the the artist imprisoned by
China now exiled and his analysis is
that China does want domination it wants
respect but it wants domination over the
next 70 years not not at all
aiya China has no intention to dominate
the world China is a still a developing
country we have a town Chung stone team
we have a dungeon challenges to develop
the country so that's how presidency
said we suitable up our country which
will consolidate our achievement we
should develop our country well that is
a fundamental task in front of the
leadership in front of the Chinese
people and China well you know China has
been a victim as it said a foreign
invasion aggression bullying humilation
and we certainly will never ever
transfer this to the other countries
well you mentioned that but then we see
these scenes in Hong Kong today and you
know we've been reporting as you heard
there let's just have a little look at
it one of the protesters today being
shot a very close range in the chest and
people saying well this Chinese
crackdown isn't showing a respect for
civil rights I can't agree with you to
describe what happened in Hong Kong is
not a crime at all
I strongly condemn the violence writers
you know this violence has been going on
for several months they challenged the
bottom line of one country to system a
challenge a rule flaw in country it
brought just one or engaged one at hoe
talks and discuss some of the Democratic
demands of the protesters no you have to
separate peaceful demonstration from a
violent rioters you talk about the
police use alive emulations because
their life was in serious threat
you know these writers who have been
short on leftist odor is the one who
used iron client club to attack please
so I would ask what happened if the same
blur things happened in your
what will be the response of a British
police in responding to such a writer's
such a violence wouldn't shoot an
unarmed protester whether live with it
really the web if their lives were in
serious drought in the main the British
police are not armed
no I don't think so I don't think so
what how the British police will
response one the Westminster Hall was
stormed by rioters you know I think we
should condemn these violence Hong Kong
is based on rule of law I think rule of
law one country two system can usually
you tell me then if these protests
continue and they continue to escalate
in terms of the violence and there is no
doubt that there is extreme violence on
both sides that then more firearms will
be used by the authorities I do hope
things will calm down I really not I
would not answer hypothetical questions
but I think things have be improved
somewhat in the past few weeks since the
chief exactly withdraw the bill and also
started composition when the various
sectors and he or she also set up what
they call it a dialogue office and
engaged in sincerity with the people
from all walks of life I think people
should gave opportunity to Hong Kong
Special Administrative government to
address their concerns we acknowledge
there are some basic deep seeded
problems like housing like opportunities
for the young people but demonstrations
violence offer no solution to this
deep-seated problems can I ask you about
the plight of the Rieger people in Qin
Jiang our correspondent Tom Cheshire has
been there recently reported from there
recently about the hundreds of thousands
or indeed millions of people being held
in prison camps there can you put a
thing on that's not true
you know how shin heung is the largest
in China it's enjoying prosperity and
the Shin young people have already like
the people are held in those prison
camps it's not a prison camp what we
call it education training center the
measure has been taken is for the
Prevention of a tourism in the Shin Jang
has been the victim of a terrorism in
terms of for the past 20 years we just
look at those files on track mr.
ambassador but you say their
re-education camps things people going
there voluntarily they're bound there
blindfold and they're being marched
along the bear buyer by police are they
going into these re-education camps
voluntarily no that's a different story
you know this is a transfer of he mates
you know I know you the the me to pick
up some clips but this is nothing to do
with the education training center the
the messer were taken are exactly for
the safety of the majority of us in
young people you know it's a part of the
UN early prevention action to prevent a
terrorism so so when there re-educated
as you put it are they free to leave yes
of course you know the basic purpose is
to educate these young people so that
they will get away get rid of these
extremist ideas they will learn some
skill they can earn their living you
know and they also know how to earn
their living by the command of the skill
and how you know they will never be
intoxicated by the extremist ideas and
lastly mr. ambassador can I ask you
about the issue of Huawei
as you know many nations including the
United States believe that while way has
very close links with the Chinese
government so much so that the United
States is is banning while ways in
involvement in development some of many
of its networks in the UK it is still
involved in our 5g network but we've
just done an interview today with the US
Commerce Secretary of Commerce Wilbur
Ross who says that the United Kingdom
should be very wary of Huawei if the UK
pulls out what were the Chinese attitude
be first I would reject totally
acquisition against huawei this is a
good company is a private company it's
nothing to do with the Chinese
government they are the leader in 5g
telecommunications I think they are here
for willing collaboration with the
British counterparts and they are
contributing to the development of
telecom industry in the UK
I do hope that UK government will make
wise decision based on the national
interest of you okay a president Trump
is not just where we Ross president
Trump is burning a lot of pressure on on
Boris Johnson we know they talked about
it together if the UK did ban Huawei
China's attitude be for instance - a
trade deal with the UK post Breck's I
think if you okay get rid of Huawei it
will send a bad message to negative
message UK's regarded as a most open
business friendly our country but who
are we what song a will sent negative
message worldwide it also sent that
message to Chinese businesses Chinese
investment here in this country so I do
hope that UK government will make a
decision based on interests of UK
national interests and in the interest
of China
y'okay collaboration mr. Liu ambassador
thank you very much indeed